foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today
is SCP 1133
object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-1133 is to be kept within a secure
testing chamber at site equipped with
one standard power socket samples of
scp-1133x should be stored in an on-site
bio research Vault should be guarded by
a minimum of one armed Personnel at all
times in order to prevent unauthorized
access
description
scp-1133 resembles an ordinary Hospital
standard intravenous fluid stand only
the infusion pump displays any anomalous
properties the tubes stand power supply
and intravenous drip bags are entirely
ordinary and can be replaced with the
exception of the tubes passing through
the infusion pump all openings on the
device are fused shut including the rear
battery compartment requiring that
scp-1133 be connected to a standard
power socket at all times all attempts
at opening scp-1133 have so far failed
as the casing has proved remarkably
resilient such that the force required
to penetrate the casing would likely
cause irreparable damage to its internal
components as a result internal
examination has been postponed until
primary research is complete the console
of scp-1133 possesses nine buttons not
present on a normal infusion pump the
first seven are labeled with a
corresponding number and the final two
with the words extract and Infuse
respectively
the remainder of scp-1133's controls are
non-functional when supplied with power
scp-1133 will display the message select
operation settings at which points
either extract or Infuse must be
selected after wedge scp-1133 will
activate if it is connected to a living
human subject if scp-1133 is connected
to a cadaver or any non-human species
scp-1133 will display the message
operation failed and shut down
if the extract setting is selected one
of the number buttons must be selected
this will cause scp-1133 to begin
extracting a substance Hereafter known
as
scp-1133x from the subject corresponding
to the number chosen selecting the
Infuse option will result in the pump
functioning as would be expected
infusing the substance placed in the
drip bags into the subject's bloodstream
only
scp-1133x can be infused in this way the
use of any other substance will result
in the message operation failed
scp-1133x appears to be synthesized
directly from the subject's bloodstream
upon extraction and breaks down almost
immediately upon entering the blood
during infusion making it almost
impossible to observe its impact on
human physiology
however both the infusion and extraction
of scp-1133x produces equal and opposite
changes in the behavior and morality of
the subject which are easily observable
subjects are not normally aware of or
disturbed by these changes even when the
subject had prior knowledge of
scp-1133's effects
to date seven different varieties of
scp-1133x have been recorded each with a
distinct color and effect and each
corresponding to a specific number on
scp-1133's Console samples of
scp-1133x have no observable effect on
the human body if administered by any
means other than
scp-1133's infusion function
all attempts to synthesize
scp-1133x in laboratory conditions have
so far failed for detailed analysis of
scp-1133x's chemical properties please
refer to document 1133 there seems to be
limits to the quantity of each variety
of
scp-1133x that can be extracted from any
given subject which seemed to vary from
Individual to individual depending on
the personality of the subject for
example subjects with a history of
kleptomania seem to have larger natural
reservoirs of scp-1133 III available for
extraction and requiring less
scp-1133-3 infusion to display more
extreme symptoms it is unknown whether
an upper limit exists for the infusion
of
scp-1133x below is a list of the seven
known varieties and their effects
scp-1133x observations
scp-1133-1
color light green
infusion effect increased appetite
subjects infused with sufficient
quantities of scp-11331 are unable to
resist the compulsion to consume any
form of food in the immediate area
including those normally repulsive to
humans including rotten food raw meat
and animal feed subjects will frequently
become violent when denied food several
d-class subjects infused with scp-1133-1
have died as a result of choking or in
extreme cases of stomach ruptures caused
by the sheer quantity consumed in all
amounts scp-11331 infusion has proved to
improve the symptoms of eating disorders
such as anorexia
extraction effect decreased appetite
subjects display A reduced enthusiasm
for food often forgetting to eat to the
point of starvation although they can
typically be induced to eat without the
application of force
scp-1133 2. color red
infusion effect heightened stress levels
and aggressive behavior those infused
with large quantities of
scp-1133-2 typically become dangerous
and violent often becoming hostile
towards Foundation Personnel following
incident 171 any experiments involving
scp-1133-2 require an additional two
armed security guards at all times
extraction effect reduced aggression and
increased docile behavior when large
amounts are removed subjects will often
refuse to defend themselves even from
violent assault given the potential for
this process to make subjects more
compliant use of
scp-1133-2 extraction and interrogations
or pacification of troublesome Personnel
is being considered pending further
testing
scp-1133 3. color yellow
infusion effect
scp-1133 appears to influence interest
in material wealth subjects typically
become obsessed with financial gain
often showing symptoms of kleptomania
subjects exposed to high amounts will
often become violently fixated on shiny
objects such as wrist watches or metal
buttons
extraction effect loss of interest in
money and material wealth generally
becoming indifferent to material
possessions as opposed to actively
generous subjects will often show
reduced understanding of money and
financial issues as well as reduced
motivation for the completion of tasks
with material Rewards
scp-1133 4. color blue
infusion effect increased egotism and
self-confidence although small infusions
can lead to beneficial increases in
confidence further amounts will likely
lead to narcissism and vanity often
resulting in violent attacks on any
Personnel the subject perceives as
insulting them
extraction effect similar to
scp-1133-2 subjects become quieter and
less assertive although they will still
defend themselves if faced with assault
extraction of the maximum quantity of
scp-1133-4 has resulted in attempted in
percent of cases
scp-1133 5.
color dark green
infusion effect increased fixation on
the possessions achievements and
privileges of others with subjects often
coming to perceive all others as better
off than themselves this has frequently
resulted in uncooperative and abusive
behavior in subjects although subjects
are not typically violent instead
preferring acts of sabotage or indirect
methods of inducing pain and distress in
those around them
extraction effect subjects disinterested
in the possessions of those around them
scp-1133-5 extraction seems to have
comparatively few detrimental effects on
subjects although there is still a high
risk of psychological damage and
in all cases
scp-1133 6.
color brown
infusion effect increased levels of
General apathy and reduced energy in
some cases showing symptoms similar to
those of moderate to severe narcolepsy
though subjected to high enough levels
of
scp-11336 enter a coma-like state and so
far no attempts bar the extraction of
scp-1133-6 have proved successful in
recovery
extraction effect increased energy
levels activity and enthusiasm in
extreme cases this can result in
hyperactivity and symptoms comparable to
attention deficit disorder although
subjects will more commonly suffer from
insomnia and mental fatigue resulting
from increased physical and mental
activity
scp-1133 7. Color Purple
infusion effect increased sexual drive
in extreme cases this results in
symptoms similar to clinical
hypersexuality subjects have frequently
resorted to violence and attempts to
satisfy the resulting compulsions which
has made testing on the effects of
scp-11337 particularly troublesome
extraction effect reduced interest in
sexual activity those having the maximum
amount extracted typically become
completely disinterested and in some
cases repulsed by the idea of sexual
intercourse
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargura
oh crap guy
the Morrigan
Rowan O'Brien
braided Peach
Dean dingus
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
segnar
your local Foundation agent
Lost Boy
and James Saba
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you